i'm joined by the world health
organization special envoy for the
global covid 19 response
and chair of global health at imperial
college dr david nabarro dr nabarro
thank you very much
for being with us so the government now
considering
uh quarantine hotels mandatory
quarantine
for arrivals in to the uk
is that the right response
certainly the need to isolate
people who may be at risk of bringing
covid into communities is
recognized as important especially
if countries are concerned to try to
reduce the risk
of new cases coming in and particularly
if they are
of a new variant but i do want to stress
that isolation is a key part of dealing
with kovid
wherever we are because the only way you
can interrupt transmission
is by isolating people with the disease
until they're free of it
either you treat them or if they don't
need treatment they must stay at home
this is key and without isolation being
done
effectively actually getting on top of
the pandemic is really difficult
by effective isolation then what would
you like
to see what does that mean
the countries that have used isolation
effectively
as as was presented in in the
introduction just now
uh countries who are requiring
people to actually stay away from other
people
and to keep away from other people if
people
do not isolate then there is a huge risk
of the virus spreading so isolation must
be
complete and one of the findings of
countries that have been successful
is that isolation is best done if it's
done under supervision
that's why the plan to introduce
quarantine hotels
makes a lot of sense it's certainly
what's worked in other parts of the
world
and it's certainly more effective than
asking people to self-isolate
unfortunately they don't necessarily for
a mix of reasons find it easy to do that
so are you suggesting that it should be
not just for arrivals into the country
but that anyone who tests positive
should go to a facility to isolate
what we're saying is that if isolation
is going to be done
it should be done properly and
effectively
whatever means a government or other
authority can use
to ensure isolation is effective should
be used
i think in practice a government has to
decide which is the technique that's
most useful
and certainly several countries have
moved towards using
hotels or some form of supervised
quarantine
to try to actually make sure that people
do isolate
and are supported while they isolate
with food and with
medicines if they need them another
requirements
the government has always avoided this
despite other countries as
we quoted australia and new zealand
doing it but now the concern
from new variants 77 cases of the south
africa variant
now in the uk nine of one of the uh
brazilian
variants questions about the vaccine
efficacy we've had some information from
moderner today at mixed news i would say
reading it what is your analysis of what
they've had to say
well i i've read the reports from
moderna i've got to read them in more
detail
i think the general view that we have is
that
new variants are going to go on emerging
all the time and the more virus there's
around in the world
the more likely the hood there is of new
variants
coming uh into notice and so
i would say that it's really important
to continue
surveillance for the new variants and
then to do the necessary laboratory
work to see whether or not the vaccines
work against them
the modern information is promising
as is the information from other vaccine
producers
most of them seem to feel that of the
variants that have
appeared so far the vaccines appear to
work
the question is will vaccines go on
working
against all newly emerging variants
the answer is we can't say at this stage
and that's why we are encouraging
all governments that can to continue
looking at the coronavirus cases that
are appearing in their communities
and check to see whether they are
showing any signs of being
one of the existing variants or even a
completely new variant
we haven't seen before this will be a
continuing reality
of this pandemic because all viruses
mutate
and it requirement is to look and see
whether or not mutations appear
that change either the transmissibility
of the virus
or the impact of the virus on people or
the degree to which
vaccines protect against the variants as
they emerge
yeah and so what we're seeing so far at
least in the lab
analysis is the moderna vaccine
effective against the variant
that was identified in the uk six times
less effective against the
south africa variant so so what's the
answer that potentially looking at a
third
booster dose well i
i mean the usual way that we act when
a virus mutates is that we look at the
vaccine and see whether the vaccine
needs to be changed
so that it is active against the variant
this is a process that's possible it
takes a bit of time because the
vaccine manufacturer has to refashion
the vaccine and then test it out
but it's doable i think the only issue
that we face is that it will take
a significant number of weeks perhaps
even months
for a vaccine to be adapted to a new
variant
and in that interval the variant can
cause a
considerable challenge for societies
what it means is
we've got to have very close cooperation
between governments checking to see
how the variants are emerging and then
the vaccine manufacturers to check that
their vaccines work
and then once finally once we've got the
vaccine adjusted
then vaccination schedules have to be
adapted what i'm suggesting is
it's a complex process and that's why
the world health organization is
encouraging all governments
to work with the who on their
immunization strategies
it's going to require constant
adaptation
in the light of new information and
really no country
i think can reasonably do this alone
we've got to have
all countries working together to be
expect to make sure that we're ahead of
the virus
and anticipating and then reacting to
variants
when they emerge it's best if countries
do this
as a whole and approach the problem as a
global problem
rather than operating independently with
their own
separate regimes and in terms of
independent regimes
the uk government has decided on a
12-week gap between
uh first dose and second dose of the
vaccine the world health organization
has expressed some concern about that
the jcvi have defended that and
suggested that perhaps it might even
lead to greater
immunity i want to get your thoughts on
that
this is a difficult one you see on the
one hand
the manufacturers have tested their
vaccines
using a particular schedule for rolling
out
and on the other hand governments are
trying as hard as they can to get as
many people as possible protected
that's led some governments to extend
the interval between vaccine doses
yet the manufacturers testing was not
done using long intervals inevitably
the world health organization which has
to work with the data provided by the
manufacturers
will come down in favor of using
the vaccine as was prescribed by the
manufacturers and not going for
alternatives
the last thing any of us wants to do is
to question a government strategy so
instead what we're doing
is encouraging all governments that are
using longer dose intervals as part of
their strategy
to be very clear with the public and
with professionals
about the rationale for the extended
doses in the end it's a government's
decision what it does
the world health organization can offer
recommendations
but we can't actually have an
alternative approach to national
governments
this is a very challenging time each
government
is really trying to get as many people
protected as possible
but we we do have to keep stating that
the manufacturers of the vaccines
offered a particular regime when they
presented they
date their data to regulators and we
need to stick with those
those uh pieces of information that come
through from the manufacturers
when when we offer our recommendations
to the world